hey on earth can optimize you during the
day that's for sure I mean if you got
problems with your brain help you focus
with alpha brain they got alpha brain
instant if you got problems with your
digestive health they're there for you
with total gut health it got stuff for
your support and vitality essential
nutrients we know about performance you
want to optimize your performance you
got shroom tech support you got clue to
mean you got creatine you got mineral
electrolytes you can stuff your immune
system like shroom tech immune viral
tech all right
this stuff is used by the owners
themselves but what about when you sleep
on it meets you have way they got
melatonin spray they got new mood all
kinds of stuff sleep how do I keep it
going
I sleep and I use the melatonin spray
hey Brennan just talking about on it
talking about what they got for us which
is pretty much everything for your body
for your biology know what I'm saying
getting that huh yeah I thought so on it
leaves even Brendan's shy about you slam
this Deathstorm your freaking ass I'm
not doing that they have slam balls yeah
I know I'm solo yoga man what they got
han solo yoga mats like star star wars
like a lot of chakras I'll tell you that
much I bro man what doesn't on it -
besides punch you in the face all right
listen shape man it's to them twice
all humans day and night 2020 yo 10% off
audit comm 10% off dues right you just
say those note fighter
everybody can use it include everybody
name somebody ionic comms last fighter
even Obama probably uses he's already in
shape plays basketball I could be
something else all right Donald Trump
hey Donald Trump let's get you on some
on it all right all right that concise
fighter we're already already rolling
yeah this is good girl Stefano and Yan
be honest be honest so what's your last
little miss Pappas up penis whatever you
want happens dude it's exciting yeah
Donna's pop at the ER us it's good to
have you guys here you know you are um
you you hug Brennan yeah and and then
you and you and I you turn your head and
you kissed his neck now that the first
time you guys are meeting yes yeah
here's the other thing
for tax buddies with the time he texts
me sit calls me babe yeah okay well you
ready comfortable you like your and your
like fashion this is their shirt I want
you to zoom in on that that's that's now
they think that's a hyena but looks a
dog more like like it's like a German
Shepherd yeah yeah maybe a coyote coyote
yeah that's not people and if I'm gonna
be completely honest with you it's not a
hot seller just have them left over in
my apartment so let's give them to the
boy yeah because really our fans aren't
loving them necessarily but we're gonna
come out with new shirts pretty soon
yeah I would I would rock your shirt
with just two hyenas back-to-back
laughing which make that we should make
that because our first logo was our
faces we superimpose our faces like that
it's to a bloody hyena that I've just
eaten out of line carcass yeah we're
like that'll be good women want to buy
that and we were wrong again you got a
big female demo well um we have our demo
is kind of like everybody it's kind of
weird like we have people who are
politically extreme one way the other
way we got guys we got girls we got a
lot of transgender people yeah well I
would say I would I would argue and
anybody can tweet at me at Kristy comedy
at history Nina's podcast we have the
biggest transgender following of any
podcast in the country ever big it's
[ __ ] true I don't know I don't have
role I don't know Joe metrics for that
I'm gonna do Bloomberg News did it don't
know if they did they did they did know
and I'm telling you at checkout this
yeah I checked because I'm telling you I
mean every I would say every [ __ ] day
every day or at least every other day
yeah we get to our DMS someone's post-op
genitalia and that tells us yeah that
because they'll say you know love you
guys going wild like well cuz we'll say
case and there's something while you did
today and people constantly puttin on a
flight to Thailand taking a piece of my
elbow making a day okay you know
take a piece of the elbow to a Brooklyn
guy yeah I'll [ __ ] take it up on
Lincoln a dick oh [ __ ] it's arcing I'll
[ __ ] mother yelled 20/20 bite and the
[ __ ] the respectfully rice patties in
for an angel just just take a big
American eat them like 20 bucks Bobby
Lee an ally one we got defense I could
say what I want to stand with you are
turkey dicks back now I want to say this
before we get go any further you're
Greek yeah sorry and I I met I met you
man a nurse who worked in the urology
department so 10,000 dicks and said who
has the biggest before I got who has the
biggest she goes biggest a excretes and
i said she says [ __ ] she goes don't beat
all the brothers and everybody else know
your black friend satan yeah no is that
true yeah you don't see well blacked you
don't see greeked
right there's no Greek so maybe she
doesn't know what she's talking she
doesn't know what she's talking about
but I appreciate you know what she said
you know I got him his Bush he's got a
full bush yeah okay all right yeah it
old-school yeah okay yeah what were you
what was your support bro
I'm taking you in right now and yeah
you're you're you represent muscular
comedy you and Delvecchio oh yeah a
couple of thick boys the problem is this
time when I take my shirt off it all
falls apart I look good in clothes
I just called by casting to recognize
the key nailed it I got leading man's
face best friend body so you know when I
take
shirt off that's why you did it
I mean if I matched it all up I'd be out
there with [ __ ] Tom Hardy who rather
scenes with hell yeah I won't you sexy
you talk like yourself that much if
you're a comedian right it's my opinion
you gotta hate yourself a little bit
yeah like I you know I've always you
know girls it's always kind of like with
me we don't want to take those when I
take my sure up and you know I said the
same thing like we thought not that it's
terrible but we thought it's gonna be a
little different
Spang yeah like I got a comes out I just
like I get up I got a lunch place - no I
got a [ __ ] a little bit of an L la well
I had a girl I dated a girl who was big
but I didn't mind cuz she had the waist
and she had just she was beautiful but
which is big big just a little too I'm a
little light in the ass for to situate
you that's a problem it was all good
then one day she was lying on her back
mm-hmm and it all flattened out her ass
flattened down okay face in the neck and
everything flat back in a puddle can't
say that heavy girls give you a comitia
for God but I'm telling you they do I
got transgender fans I can say what I
want you know said that was
what's-his-name who did a 300 Butler
about Jerrod bronze rock pop he said
like everyone knew him from the movie
300 biggest movies ever done right he's
[ __ ] shred Cydia well now yeah has my
song reflects it that's up with girls
he's the sloppy puddle that's what it is
he gets a little swag your jets are out
yeah I'm a bot full dead because what I
do you know is there's a lot of things
like you know we have sex with the
lights off I try to keep the shirt on or
I wear things that flatter my shoulders
or whatever armor and even even dick
pics I send out I send out this one dick
pic no it's really it gets to Verizon
FiOS remote I got crazy questions when I
put a Verizon FiOS remote in my sweat
pants Verizon what Verizon FiOS TV
remote I put one of my sweats about two
years ago and I send that out as my hog
and then girls like oh my god fill me up
and then when it gets down to it I got
to turn all the lights off get him
really wet yeah you know I brought like
a honey dick oh yeah cuz I got I got I'm
not saying I have a small dick no you
know I'm about I would say I said this
the other day and I'm stand by I would
say
about six six inch dick settlement warts
that's all ya know she guarded so
whatever one output my HPV cream on ago
quartz I got one that typically is right
by the pee hole and the kind of coin you
ever recurring war problem no but you
know I mean listen you're gonna get a
little speed bumps on your dick you know
we haven't found out here we haven't fun
out yeah I don't have HIV yeah I like
your sky off if you tie off at the base
and right right behind the balls that
that you don't have to use the remote
cuz that'll keep it somewhat hard right
in half is I mean your I have a DC penis
yeah here in the game yeah why the game
not a big deal welcome to the show well
let's put it this way yeah sent sent my
boys into the crimes with mate yeah sent
them a picture of peace I didn't know ma
but they needed to understand what they
were dealing with that's where we learn
respect yeah yeah and and how about the
first time I met you I understand what
the truth is I met you were both at a
you're gonna piss and I'm taking abyss
and he just [ __ ] that Mongoose relax
you know what and that's what an
honestly man I played sports in high
school and it was kind of like you know
when I was a junior in high school as
the captain of the team and that there
were you know anytime the freshmen come
on in sometimes refreshments would make
varsity it's like listen babe welcome to
the team play checkout and a guy would
be like no I'm not gonna tell them like
why what do you gay or something yeah
and then they say no I'm not gay I'm
like well then pull it out yeah then I
[ __ ] see you know you tickle his balls
a little bit
we're playing ball tickling what was
your feet guess what I guess what
position what position linebacker that's
what I would say no no I went to an
all-boys Catholic High School didn't
have a football team because it was two
stalks I didn't play football now I play
basketball in baseball that's what I
played so yeah yeah but you know I
Division three basketball there was a
girl on the other team white basketball
I played the white girls white smart man
yeah well that's why when a warrior
could shout out Chris Mullin shout out
Chris Mullin law said white smart ass
because that's these white boys in
Division three they're not going there
for sports or going there for their
education right so you're talking I mean
they're running Phil Jackson offense
with no skill yeah let's be sure we
explain that yeah there you go
thanks for looking out guys couple I'm
says this is a race to sandwich right
now yeah yeah no no trust tree I was
gonna say you and I and everybody's
diverse yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] Greek
Mexican each other you can tell I'm
Greek but a lot of people just think I'm
Mexican yeah like you know we had a show
on the bracket MSG local TV in New York
and they said we love Chris with that
Mexican kid fatso with that Mexican was
sitting down construction workers argue
that kids from the bracket I was okay
goes it's good you and the fat Mexican
get back on is Nokia 2008 yeah what are
we gonna do where Brooklyn kids yeah he
grew up in like the you know upper s
Park Slope Brooklyn judge might woke
dope yeah and I grew up where I was like
you know it's blue-collar
Brooklyn yeah are they carry Brooklyn
brothers corner raised in Bensonhurst oh
yeah yeah yeah it's out of the family
nice you ever go back there visitor when
I was a kid I used to go back to see my
great grandmother who was two died in 98
or some I got good genetics yeah you
look good you are healthy keep both you
guys yeah it's a lot of help out here
yeah yeah it's a lot of you guys in New
York no nobody's really it's Reid I got
packets of dayquil in my pocket right
now we're not healthy kids yeah we get
nervous
the only one I know who doesn't touch
like bad food and his from Andrew
Schultz doesn't eat bread bread yeah why
are you Schultz is run in New York City
like it's North Korea yes tells people
he doesn't poop then that's just what
you have to do yeah you know Schultz you
shower boy but you're kidding right
these are fun it's marketing to that and
these are [ __ ] he's really [ __ ] yeah
no we're on the Schultz where we are
Schultz disciples yeah but it's the
thing as if Schultz ever gets a little
lippy I'll still [ __ ] screw his head
on yeah that's what he knows about it
horse boxing videos and I said all I got
to do is tickle your balls for three
seconds yeah and that's it we'll be in a
relationship for two years you'll never
know it [ __ ] you being metaphorical
right now you know if that kid [ __ ]
if people like that want to pop off at
me [ __ ] corner them at the communist
army or out here at the common store
tickle their balls yeah and the next
thing you know they're bringing me home
for holidays and we're in a gay
relationship out all over the world on
his SkyMiles cuz you selling tickets to
me right now
and then he won't even [ __ ] realize
what happened until it's three years and
two [ __ ] [ __ ] he's gonna pop in their
lap so yeah okay so a buck chasing is a
phenomenon in the gay community I've
heard it's a phenomenon in the gay
community where they go out and they
have the thrill because sometimes having
so much sex that you just nothing pops
off anymore so
there have sex with God the guy won't
have HIV we'll have sex with a guy who
has HIV and the thrill of catching the
bug will get make them come yeah bug
chase that's right yeah I mean that's
what are they that for three years you
won't even know it yeah won't even know
it's you [ __ ] house yes what age what
it's go away
yeah now it's not my cup of tea but it's
brave yeah it's [ __ ] everybody's out
here with brave comedy specials will
[ __ ] come into crit CDs well my
daughter's watching yeah it's great and
we do have a big trends they send his
emails that just say thank you thank you
so we get a lot of things to young kids
no no kids married nothing just got
married okay and just got married
ah what house yeah comedy scene you guys
do we're poor poor you guys we'll sit
you guys will do mostly the Comedy
Cellar or where else do you stand for
the most part yeah comedy so understand
yeah yeah yeah flapping your wings they
New York yeah you know you know talking
about you know I mean people are you
know the differences you know our peers
at the Comedy Cellar we're talked about
like we're the good comedians here and
it's like you guys are eating pigeons
yeah you know I mean these guys aren't
flying Tesla's out here in LA like what
do we do we want to do we want I got a
family to feed I got a family I got a
gay husband I'm not blind you married
you're married to a guy just for your
[ __ ] transplants and I'm even believe
you're gay I swear to god I'll tell you
this right now I know this for one item
100% I'm telling you I'm 100% not gay
but I 100% not straya
I'll tell you that
and I [ __ ] swear to god I fall in
love with man I have sex with women
that's what I do
heroes yeah I swear to God do I start
holding him right now I'll get so horny
I'll [ __ ] tacky but he does what he
does yes a girl over his house he'll
call me for a 45 minute conversation
yeah to get going and then he's ready to
go hurt I need thought the only way it
can come as insightful man I was gonna
blow to hell weekly all in Denver I
couldn't get three hours of girls Blom
and my skin was she's like Reese Arkham
sides of me I put on Obama speech blast
a lot I shop as soon as he's [ __ ] you
know like slack smart men he's a smart
black guy teams you got you guys joints
fans jet skies New York Giants Giants
Yankees my team's our Giants Yankees New
York Islanders and Serena Williams yeah
all right nah but I just like women's
tennis you know yeah yeah yeah I used to
work at the US Open when I was a kid
born oh that ball boy court attendance
and it was one of those things where
it's like when you work at the tennis
see you know that when did the US Open
the French Open Wimbledon they get the
elite kids politicians kids and the
royal family will have their kids do
Wimbledon court attendance real hell
that's not how it works in Europe and
they get dirtbags from Queens in
Brooklyn yeah so we were out there 16 17
years old with these [ __ ] balls you
know my Pat Finnegan patty fly balls one
you know we worked 20 years together
there and you know and then Serena
Williams went that my friend hooked up
with her
Wow a percent yeah I'll say that right
to the [ __ ] white guys yes he they
were under the blue there was peak
practice courts P 1 through 7 and right
under the bleachers yeah that's where
the big pros were Platts dude I've seen
everybody's dick by the Roger Federer
Andy Roddick all these guys because I've
restocked two towels and I know so my
daughter are working with a right nice
piece because my job was to restock the
towels but then sometimes I jump out of
the iSchool or when they were naked and
I ha
kepta chol look at you guys accrue just
fine I swear to [ __ ] I got a boy my boy
Scotty karate that used to work down
there was [ __ ] rip jack kid and he
hooked up with Serena Williams and they
did it he was giving a tennis racket up
my ass Bloomberg News and this about
also the sarena stuff absolutely do I
believe that yeah no but we get rid all
the time didn't New Yorker wrote about
the New York Times yeah yeah do you guys
live close to each other
yeah we probably actually couple blocks
Labor Day he actually just moved up to
another like two hours away upstate and
I'm gonna [ __ ] burn his house down
two hours we got like an hour my heart
it's my wife wanted to do it you know
let her dream now yeah but you have a
kid your dad I got a four year old
daughter but but and you know I'm
spending all my she's my best friend but
you know Yanis he's kind of like a life
partner to me now he's moving so I want
to get Joe DeRosa nephew guys no jobs
arose a great community who looks enough
like Yanis so i want to get him into the
neighborhood because I want to just
pretend in tennis I'll put him on a
leash I'll [ __ ] spank and I'll make
him do what I what no surrogate but now
no yeah and I'll just be like you I'm
gonna call you Yanis yeah got good ideas
you gotta give him that you got great
give them that it's have good ideas yeah
how long
what a pack of his card generally the
best card yeah I was just joking around
a couple years Mike Scott talked about
the Japanese got what was [ __ ] comment
about the you knees though the unis I
will say that yeah tell me I will say I
am NOT you know being of German heritage
now you know 40% of the instruction calm
German heritage I do not support the
Nazi ideology I think what they did was
horrible but those uniforms were [ __ ]
kids yeah designed by Hugo Boss Frye
boots yeah I mean he they had an eye for
nice fashioned shadow Andrew Schultz
he'll [ __ ] make a video of this now
shirts to dharmaraja Luftwaffe yes s
here and the British Army America's
enemies have they look pretty flashy
look at that look at that Nazis Hey
there was a kid they were lit yeah they
were let now the only disgusting
ideologies but really nice [ __ ]
uniforms I take a guy like that I put
that coat on he wouldn't know what hit
him he wouldn't know one you look at him
ler if you go to that last you go boss
really design it yeah Hugo Boss is the
true design that's what it and that's
what we talk about a lot on our podcast
like selective outrage and a couple of
truths it's like Hugo Boss design the
uniforms mercedes-benz built the tanks
but nobody wants to boycott that like
let's just pull down uniforms yeah
created the upholstery with the Nazis
engines you know this race the reason
why you have you go boss thugs into
whatever you would wear some pictures up
it's because of the Nazis got it you got
the Nazi contract I don't know what that
I'll show this on camera how do you
think about that yeah and that's our
podcast history I mean it's where we're
like you know it's just it's funny first
but we're talking about history and just
like there's things that happen in
history that it's like you could say
whatever you want whatever woke dope
[ __ ] fine we're all about it but it's
like let's let's find the truth in
history yeah and then we do that yeah
but it's funny give
another one like um like nose your
biggest episode or best battle creep
maybe Battle of Crete was a good episode
battles Oakland battle Brooklyn was in
the Revolutionary War but then we find
things out like you know Christopher
Columbus everyone's like they were
pulling that they want to get the statue
out of Columbus Circle in New York City
and it's like you know
listen I'm [ __ ] I got an Italian last
name I don't really care it's a [ __ ]
statue but then when we start to look at
the atrocities and how many people he
kills like yeah sure he killed people
absolutely did but you know smallpox
killed the most people but you know you
talked to these kids right now they're
like no cancel Columbus it's like you
can't take that Butte that's at you is
huge and beautiful absolutely you you to
take that out is to take away
Cantus of history you can't tell you
crazy we're done Confederate flags in
fact I believe Christopher Columbus was
Spanish wasn't it was he was Spanish yet
he was Spanish
yeah well by Ferdinand and yeah and if
he was here today he would [ __ ] come
here and discover the country and then
we throw him right back over the wall
yeah you weren't though cuz your eyes
came no no no no it's um
yeah we just uh I know Christopher
Columbus and then what else did we find
out you know Gandhi everybody loves
Gandhi had 12 year old wives just like
people want to select honey trapped us
Gandhi did take baths with 14 year old
15 16 year old girls when he so he was
having sex it wasn't at his mother's
deathbed okay I guess that's what caused
him to take this valve celibacy right
the idea was for that he was freaking
out he would so he was he did some
[ __ ] he would sleep with and take
baths with so the legend goes beautiful
young girls to to sort of tempt himself
and overcome the temptation yeah I know
but and I am definitely fun I would
imagine he had to have been [ __ ] them
and I think that's that's a little
revisionist history yeah yeah it's like
you could we've all the or every
everybody in history if you look deep
enough you're gonna find some some you
like that Martin Luther King used to
beat the [ __ ] out of his wife it's like
you know there's a prostitute what it's
not what do you want me to do and it's
just there's a thousand examples she
doesn't mean that the man that all of us
are flawed
all of us have Darkseid's only comes
with loss though or they say it makes
him human they're just human though that
but that's my point of him completely
simcha so in that that woman who did
Hannah Hannah Gatsby Lynette yes she
said she basically was calling basically
saying that you cannot separate the man
from the art and Picasso was Picasa be
kappa cos hole and that your Picasa yeah
we should dismiss the guy because he
treated women unfair I can't do but I
disagree completely he was a ground
before is Lucas different different
times man like he and King said this
Stephen King said Stephen King's very
liberal guy and Stephen King said when
you talk about Oscars being so white
that there's definitely an argument and
all that basilar art shouldn't have
diversity actually as a as a as a quota
art should just be good art regardless
of who creates it sure we don't need to
see who creates it if it's good art it
doesn't matter who it is sure that it
should rest on that I'm not looking for
diversity in my art I'm looking for for
good just look even Ben Franklin a bunch
of hos of course man if one's default
yeah yeah he used to Ben Franklin if
syphilis have used to go to use directly
no idea he died he died at 84 85 I don't
think he was having sex then so I'm
gonna have to no but okay he did have
syllabuses syphilis because he quotes up
your spine supposed to eat your brain
and then he had leisure look now he died
syphilis might have and certainly but I
don't think does that mean he had sex
like in his in his 80s and then but he
said yeah there was no kale juice back
then the killer simplest Franklin likely
died of at MP Emma and infection this
morn is live the chest wall you know
okay but okay so maybe didn't know I
write enough about it there was not
enough he was 84 there you go why he did
a lot of [ __ ] though but I do know
that he would he would make up things
like make up reasons to like get France
to have to like go to Paris for like
some convention or some treaty that was
kind of like [ __ ] cuz he was just he
was famous here he had yeah yeah and all
the ones love Boston that's why he's on
the hundred dollar bill baby yeah I know
what he said when he when they were done
with the continent he was the oldest guy
when they drafted the league something
called the US Constitution right and the
moment said what were you doing in there
what did you what did you do in there
and he said we created a republic madam
if you can keep it
yes I like it if you can keep her then
he went like this
just [ __ ] like this yeah when George
Washington got word that the army after
the Revolution has laid son he was a
badass
after every freedom too at the end of
his after a Revolutionary War and he
found out that the army hadn't been paid
for a while Congress was moving very
slowly and he was very afraid there was
gonna be a coup right and there's a
famous story of Franklin I had a flair
for the theatrical and he came up and he
was a heat one that he was the general
who was revered right taller than most
they say probably six three and and but
but dress treat him nice not a voice and
welcome leader I always wanted to be an
actor a parent right yeah and got up
anyway game very very dramatically took
his glasses and put them on and said
forgive me gentlemen for I have grown
near blind in defense of my country and
the point was no one had suffered like
Washington yes and teeth well no one he
would he'd been there the whole time
through thick and thin and if there and
he gave them a long speech about how
government should look move slowly right
and that that is important and then when
he decided when they said do you want to
be as [ __ ] up talk about history and
he said he said I did not fight this
revolution were to be george ii because
King George he was roar and when King
George found out that he refused to be
king yeah it would be president at a
pressure of the populace you gonna be I
said if he did that he's the greatest
man ever lived
- I'm out Abe Lincoln all right get out
your notepads he was tall he could hold
an axe out at arm's length how about you
know what's funny about Abe Lincoln is
they don't have any recordings of his
voice so the way he talked real deep
that's all no idea yeah
they have no idea it could be in high
pitch like a chair cough Howard Stern
they had no idea yeah it could have been
you just make that up yeah
notice ounds like Michelle wall yeah
yeah he's a sweetheart she is wait
sweetie I ran into her in New York and
she gave me a hug
she's the best I didn't even know I saw
it's a comic store and I got scared and
I she looked at me I was gonna say hi
and I get intimidated well she's so
smart
oh yeah smart smart no she you guys came
up together like Michelle wolf schultzy
I did mark Normand I came up in the 30s
I'm an old kid how are you 44 right he
looks really young
stephannie how are you I'm 35 years old
are you a kid don't believe him about
the same okay I came up with yeah
Michelle wolf Michael che Pete Davidson
all those peeps I came with like Nate
forgets he's Dan solar generators on Dan
Soder medium rival high schools but we
love each other now play all right
against each other yeah in high school
he shot the Overland Trail Blazers shot
this McGill Buffaloes anyways the manga
smoke Nate bargatze nicest person I've
ever met in comedy great yeah yeah I
forgot seize a month yeah he's my
personal he's a monster
he'll drink your milkshake yeah yeah
from there will be blood yeah you can't
say today without even telling you how
many tickets all NATO bust open his
laptop and tell you how many tickets you
sold better wet it yes push the kid
selling you know the kid is like cargo
pants he's the last one that blew up off
Netflix I guess we won't talk about a
guy who literally got on Netflix it was
yeah but as soon as people are talking
about it you're good
9:8 Birds Otzi or whatever yeah no he's
great all the but we feel like you know
I mean in LA it's like all the podcast
and community you guys have it's like
that's the new [ __ ] goes we want to make
millions of dollars with a sock without
shoes everybody's [ __ ] guys my age for
guys my you started this 20 years ago 25
years ago 30 it's so interesting to see
how much the Internet has it's you guys
I envy you 30 or something or else
you've long you can make a living on
such a high level it'd be used to be
back when when you know we were all
doing stand-up you didn't make more than
5 grand a weekend tops house maybe 10
because maybe but not even then because
you just didn't have access to you know
your own marketing but in time right
because every time like I would uh I
forget who it was baby was forget to the
[ __ ] it was some old school commune was
just talking about how back then there
was like five spots for guys that were
moving tickets so I have to get on
freakin a late night show like Carson
and though than that there is about five
guys doing the death thing now there's
so many avenues it's like you can't you
know you so many funny people are
getting discovered and making a living
doing just a different time yeah I'm
gonna be able to talk at your ear and
then watch the blood come out and drink
it like a [ __ ] about you chick looking
at that one because I know some guys are
tortellini cuz when I see a [ __ ]
tortellini like that I know you're a
fighter and I know that you're gonna put
up a good fight but make no mistake I
will nibble that and I'll get that juice
that [ __ ] solid oh absolutely
it's hard it's hard so am I not a
protein
hey let me say I always thought and I
asked you this Ben said when you came up
in New York and doing stand-up they came
out here but I was thought the New York
guys were like so kind of like almost
[ __ ] and then now you guys are out
here like Schultz Normand out soda all
you guys are [ __ ] it's nice as [ __ ] yeah
and I don't get what you guys don't work
more together like I'm learning that
from you here everybody we all yeah it's
a Niko's what that's why I like not all
our peers but a lot of you know Schultz
ease and all those guys team Dylan who's
come out here that's what we're doing
now - were like no know what this is
well he'll that other yeah well because
we learned it from you guys we watched
you and then we're like oh that's what
we should be doing yeah now that's what
we're doing and it's only benefiting
everybody York New York and Boston as
always as a comic you were your own I
did this joke with that you're sweating
profusely take your shirt off
I'm sorry I'm so hard we did our first
meat-eater was how long ago probably
five years ago first meat eater and I
and Rogen said hey man he said you and I
represented comics now and I and I went
yeah you know that unified Bunch
and he started laughing because when
nobody was right but I will say that
rogue and I took a dictator like I don't
miss a dictator I took up a [ __ ] team
captain like Grogan got hold up nobody's
gonna be mean to these new comics no
it's not dog do our friend they're here
to do a job
everyone be [ __ ] cool don't bump
somebody for two hours no you know a
little in New York I've never done that
all that doesn't happen here anymore
no we yeah well we know like in New York
Michaela bump a few guys but whatever
yeah but that was because the system was
like there was only a couple spots so
everybody had to compete for those
couple spots and now it's like a
speedboat era where you build your own
boat and just zip around I think I think
Rogen's obviously he's at his level so
you're gonna do what the most successful
guys doing he's his thing is be nice
there's room for everybody
not everyone follows that but Ari
Shaffir when he left LA who was at UM
store door guy blew up as a comedian
he's so talented
then went to New York and was like what
are you guys doing why I guess I'm
winging each other now Ari's really
people don't think about the guy master
of Labor though right
it's been like [ __ ] [ __ ] it was over
it's just it's always been New York is a
place it doesn't put up with nonsense
all for sure and so but think about
thing about this cynical think but at
burrs age and success think of me comic
spur helps now yeah
besides Rogen there ain't no one even
close think about all the [ __ ] that does
for comics I know
Comedy Central show about helpin comics
yeah he does so much stuff I know it's
he launched all you know his own network
yeah helps calm but I think most
comedians in New York City now we know
that you know or at least the ones that
we hang out with like we get it like
we're like yeah of course you know but I
don't think we were ever really like
that like we just are late to the
podcast game in the sense like I was I
don't think I don't never saw you honest
be mean to anyone I hope my mother and
father always like just treat everybody
the same like I remember I had a manager
when I first started he like treated
this waitress like a [ __ ] third class
know you're out I don't yeah I don't
care what you can get from I don't want
to be around that that's disgusting here
like I didn't learn that unless you yeah
gonna grow up like that so so I think
now it's starting to be like hey let's
all help each other because it's like
you know I I feel like in the New York
like you said it's being cynical like
even when Andrew first started like you
know YouTube and all that needs [ __ ]
crushing and me and Jana it's like yeah
this shelters great we're like on Team
Schultz like go get it you know you go
to the comedy selling people like really
YouTube it's like yeah really YouTube
that's the new [ __ ] Network like what
do you worried about CBS still nobody
cares nobody cares nobody cares man
you know the business has changed so
yeah and people still don't get it
yeah it's really interesting yeah but
also what Schultz is doing is also brave
because he's putting content out there
that he can't so he's posting content
then that next city goes to he can't use
that same [ __ ] he's supposed to new
content oh yeah so anyone anyone hang on
keep up yeah trying to try it oh yeah
you as icky how hard is come up with new
content that you're gonna post to sell
tickets yeah it better be good
that's it every week every month that's
how much he's writing absolutely but
[ __ ] yeah we off his scrotum
absolutely everybody yeah no yeah do we
know we only see Schultz right now yeah
yeah I know all you guys excitable we're
trying well I mean our podcast our
podcast has like grown really like a lot
in the past like two three months and
now
we're hoping after all this stuff it
continues to grow because I mean our
fans you know it's nowhere near the
amount of downloads or fan base you guys
have but the loyalty is crazy like we
sold out the Gramercy Theatre in New
York at on a midnight show you know like
we're everywhere we go now tickets are
sold its loyal loyal loyal fan base so
it's [ __ ] great because it's like you
know you're talking to these people for
an hour two hours a week every week it's
like it's almost like a family member
they're like oh I'm gonna come to know
you I know you they'll come up to like
how's your daughter I'm like well also
you guys are funny
happy Friday we'll try it how many
people try the excuse oh so it's also
doing stand-up for 10-15 years how long
have you been doing it I've been doing
stand-up I started in 2009 so - perfect
started headlining in 2014 ten years ten
you've been headlining 4014 I was a
pediatric physical therapist and then I
and then I left that to do a new comedy
which was wild and boil a year on 2005
so like yeah
there's like 15 16 to be smen thank
watching the other day Lorelei Schultz
produced that yeah dredge that yeah yes
it's on YouTube yeah yeah we've got a
nice diverse episode we got Moe Mayer
who's a Muslim American we got Al Jolson
who was the who was the originator of
the blackface yeah in the 1920s Tyson
was on a pod really yeah it's just a
random he likes history
he's artists um he went wild he told us
that Neil deGrasse Tyson told us if you
put Jeff Bezos its money if you laid
Jeff Bezos his money out in cash it
would stretch from planet earth to the
moon back and forth eight times yeah
that's how much money how much money
that can ask yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] cash
baby say Dacula sorry boys and Tino on
Andrew Santino's been on burber came on
and Hillary came r1f come on I think to
help but I mean so nice he just got yeah
yeah bill burr Jim Gaffigan yeah we
heard
hold on was it Julia Roberts though in
blackface no what it was Harold we had
Harriet Tubman in news check it out stop
you guys I I just have trouble believe
that you're paranoid kid murderers who
played Harriet Tubman are a tumin on and
then her brother came on and he had it
he was like you know like Buffalo Bill
he had his dick and balls between his
legs and he was calling South Harriet
Ockman yeah and he was there Harriet
Tubman's at 201 years old she does
[ __ ] kedo yeah
no have you ever done a podcast we got
accused of lying so many times I'm sorry
I'm not questions every I beat the [ __ ]
yeah I know you're over there bro was he
not look like an honest guy he does I'm
yes he's been honest since he walked in
the door I walked in here eating rice
perhaps kept kissing me on the net what
kind of ghosts I guess - UFC fighter
right on the neck you insulted our Asian
brethren / I [ __ ] love it should be a
lot of spread don't you have a and I dug
it you know was it a show or like a pre
show on Comedy Central I had a show yeah
that's that's that's why I discovered E
that's great about that's what's great
about never I signed a whole huge deal
nice exclusive deal with Comedy Central
is great I appreciate it so much and
they put me on it on an interstitial
show for five minutes every other Friday
night at 11:30
he's always great the exposures [ __ ] to
fit a snow but it was weird I was like a
lead-in to the main show you show you
talking no then they play like tosh
point-o yeah how's the guy well no it's
a stupid question I had an hour-long
special on Comedy Central called size 38
waist so that that was out are you 38
I'm a 38 now but now I got a new special
coming out on comedy stars let's call it
size 36 waist my goal at the end of my
careers have five specials all my waist
sizes
he has like an abnormally wide ass I got
a lunch lady ass I got an LA let me see
yes you also have a bi is that a mole
you might want to hit some day for about
some waters okay you're asking I get to
miss the power though you can hit all
you I don't think my ass is made on
white power
I don't know sloppy joes yeah yeah I got
it I got a skin tag on my ass and you
know but but the thing is with me is I'm
friendly with my present now I read a
lot of heart tall so I'm friendly what
my present yeah and I don't think about
shit's not gonna matter in five months I
don't give no more than five minutes I'm
gonna pull my ass and balls I'll pull
them out yeah it's not gonna matter
wherever you are there you are yeah
exactly Jen you say friendly your
present and you do it yeah and you know
I just saw yeah it felt good it felt
good to breeze out my out farted before
and it just felt good to breeze it out
yeah but the economy central it's not
there you know I'm doing the second I
I'm doing the second our special we're
gonna film it in June in Chicago and
then and then and then I have an
animation show in development and listen
and you know when we're on farm on phone
calls with them now developing the show
but I know how it goes now I'm just you
know I'm all about the podcast and I got
my two feet in this new digital world I
absolutely want to get stuff on Comedy
Central I love them but it's like
whatever they want me to do you know
they're calling me they're like how do
you feel about the subjective truth of
your character I'm like what do you want
who do you want me to voice to get Hasan
Minhaj you want me be transgender what
the [ __ ] do you want to do just put on
have Aquafina do it I don't give a [ __ ]
it's gonna watch the show so let's just
give me the money
yeah put it in my pocket do your [ __ ]
cartoon cancel it because whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do guy I'm doing the
podcast and that's what my ticket sales
are coming from so I'm just trying to
you know you listen how many people
actually you would know this more I
don't hear people talking about Comedy
Central at all I'm no David Spade show
does well on those walks out it just got
renewed for I think another 20 episodes
yeah I think I can say that that got
renewed yeah it's a great place to hide
you're special
if you want to hide it yeah like our boy
in Edwards has special on there I was on
the road I wanted to see it and it aired
whatever on Friday night and I was like
you know then I hide my shows I got done
I was like ah [ __ ] I'm looking for I
can't find huge look it was one of those
decisions I had when they came with me
for with the deal out like you know I
got a daughter I co-parent it's like I'm
raising a family here so I'm like I got
to do this to make the money but I'm
aware like I promote it as much as I can
but I'm I'm realistic it's like nobody's
really gonna watch it Friday at midnight
but hopefully the digital streams get up
but even if it does and all I really
care all I'm even thinking about from my
specialist I don't care
the arc of the hour I mean even if it
was on Netflix I mean who can't even
watch an hour anymore in this ad a shuts
off at 26 so all I'm thinking about is
the comic they cut off at toys 60-minute
special I'm just thinking about how many
one minute Instagram Abul clips or
two-minute three-minute algae TV clips
can I have that those will get shared
around but would it be smarter because
we know according to Netflix stats that
most people they don't watch the full
hour but they don't do it in one sitting
right they cut off after 26 minutes so I
was talking to Brooke Christ about this
he goes they once they gave me those an
analytics my closer I put up at the
front because I know I have to hit him
in the [ __ ] because they're not a lot
the much the majority 70 percents not
gonna make it to my closer sure are you
here to write in the [ __ ] mouth at
the front yeah it might go a little
further but either way they leave going
damn he was a beat he was great even
though I only saw 10 15 minutes of it
yeah that crazy it's very sorry but
wouldn't be we know these analytics
right we know these aunt why are people
doing shorter specials why are people
don't know cuz I think it's conditioned
thinking it's the same reason when you
go to a comedy club and they're like you
know giving check spots out when it's
the only show of the night or there's
fine it's not saying on the road you're
doing an hour because you have to right
yeah well you know you're doing an hour
and 15 where because that people come to
see a show so people are like get a get
a babysitter right they if I can go to
dinner they pay for park now you got to
give them what they're doing you gotta
get our exact power people I'm saying
with Netflix with Comedy Central show
team looks like your honor
if we know the analytics are 27 minutes
why the [ __ ] is everybody doing that
here's my quick
here's my question if you did a half
hour do you think people would turn off
at 15 minutes well they're doing that
the 15 mins Comedy Central's doing that
but there's a short Comedy Central is
doing they're gonna do 10 minute bits
and I like 10 min killer 10 minute sets
yeah Netflix is doing 30 minute special
yes I've heard of 20 minute specials
people are that now they're opening up
to it I think for us all that matters is
that a lot of people watch it and so we
can sell tickets but here's the thing we
think about what schultzy is doing what
a lot of us are doing is when you post a
clip that's six minutes long yeah that
clip is gonna sell more tickets for you
general right your hour absolutely does
that because thank you
like you I I was laughing but you're
doing about the way your girl talks oh
yeah my baby kids mom yeah phenomenal
special you take so you take that and
you post that that's gonna sell more
Taylor than worse ours no you may not
need a [ __ ] hour for me I swear to
god what I care about is selling as many
tickets I think that's what I give up
that and that's why that's where the
money that's why we're all but we're all
stuck in this I gotta get an hour this
place this place to this place oh yeah
if you're Chappell or you're rock or
you're Rogen or you're Burr and you know
paper tiger and they're paying you 40
million to produce that hour no I
already sell in arenas and stadiums and
you're Kevin Hart that makes sense
I just if you're these other great I
don't know and I'm not saying off the
answers I'm not saying don't shoot ours
I'm saying that at all I'm just saying
when I look at the analytics I'm like I
don't know man we agrees in an ironic
how like the farther technologies come
the more it's sort of come back full
circle to the beginning like now the
live performance is the special thing
yes sir because it's so easy to see
somebody on a screen anywhere it's so
common they're like now talk radios back
with podcast and people want to get to
know the the personality ballad they
want because because everything's
instant and like everything's on screens
and yeah how much Rogan oi says podcast
some people don't need to I'm sweating
small towel you want me to be that towel
yeah I'll do it I guess I do now I'll be
the small town tomorrow kiss you on the
lips I just got lost your eyes look at
me let me get strapped all right now
Rogan [ __ ] said a lot of guys say is
when they write a book it used to be you
had to go through first of all you write
a book your publisher once you write a
much longer book than you need to
that's a bit secret and publishing it's
got to be 300 pages or whatever for
whatever reason so now you sell that
book now you go on a book tour you do
one episode of Rogan these people get
their idea from that book across first
of all you don't really have to read the
book usually second of all more people
hear about that book or something
ten years than in ten years well anybody
from Sam Harris - Neil deGrasse Tyson
these are public intellectuals that make
their living selling books they do one
episode okay no daddy's giving whatever
so did they sell more books from that
three hours than they do in ten years I
mean I'm talking about I think with Sam
Harris talking about he's he sells it
bestseller he goes I I can sell more
books in you know in this three hours
than I do and how do you think on it was
created yeah they were doing alright and
then they came on Rogan and Alpha Brett
like yeah Corso Pitt but you know we
talk a lot about ro you know yeah he's
whatever he literally has v-bit name of
show name a show named show huh yeah
it's the biggest show on the planet sure
we know you an Uyghur then Stern it's
bigger than ya Oh Bubba not leavin close
it's bigger than Kim always bigger than
ninety not hold on not they're not in
the same [ __ ] lanes as far as
straight-up eyes earballs
yeah it's not even the same sorry again
I've named a [ __ ] now he is big he's
my boy so I defended but yet this is
just numbers that humans turn yeah not
even close
you guys are answers on PBS compared to
yeah yeah that's you know stuff yeah
that's all [ __ ] what that's what
that what all those numbers all that
then we could tell a name oh yeah oh
yeah here's one for you name last time
so what dude you hear that Stern
interview go ahead yeah go ahead you New
York piece of [ __ ] I'm a stern fan only
tell no you're not no you're [ __ ] not
no I agree with you and I can see it oh
you we can see it from our own ticket
sales are from our own social medias
when you do serious I mean you don't get
a single father I mean it's like it's
like you set it into your [ __ ] toilet
but when you do these podcast like I'm
sure you know hopefully fans like us
they're you know the numbers jump the
other you and then it's like the tickets
jump so it's like we it's so obvious
like it's not even though we wouldn't
have to give us a millisecond of we
would know right away if it's between
Joe Rogan or The Tonight Show it's like
yeah you just if it's between the
fighter in the kid in The Tonight Show
you go on the fighter in the kid if you
want to sell tickets I'm not saying
anteye Tonight Show but it's like it's
we want to sell tickets yeah I think
it's the industry trying to just
convince people that people are still
watching TV when nobody's watching
dude I dunno what he's watching but this
is what they decide the outcome but this
is what so like on Jimmy Kimmel or a
Jimmy Fallon or who's the who's a big
British guy James Corden see straight oh
yeah all all they do all they do is do
they do segments to upload the next
mortises no one's watching that a new
segments to upload so they get the
digital MARPOL karaoke my show my show
my show we just got numbers and I did
something executives downstairs my show
on ABC is I think the second biggest
show right now it's huge I'm very happy
to do it it doesn't help me one iota
selling take what if I didn't have this
I'd be a dead yeah yeah yeah and that's
why I only take 80% yeah I saw it wolf
Jana saw it especially in like 2012 2013
at a really 2011 2011 he was one of the
first guys to hit it on YouTube that
huge character maureesa rodriguez das
said it was he went [ __ ] viral in New
York and now and then at that time I
remember when you and you said this
we're at Caroline's he was headlining
Caroline's and at that time Chris D'Elia
wasn't what he was now because he's now
it's obviously he's [ __ ] humongous
sack now but at that time he was on
Whitney the a sitcom and the rooms
weren't even close to he didn't sell it
half the tickets jana sold and Yanis was
adding shows because it was just YouTube
now definitely get Chris and now but
that's what snapchat very cool it's a
fine chewy guy we were watching Chris
last night it's like he's [ __ ]
murdering on stage so you get it but
it's like but and then it's and it's
like yeah he's an amazing stand up but
it's like don't even why he's packing
the arenas is because it's like the
internet the internet yeah it was the
but but also the in and I went oh my god
whatever Chris does that's a funny bit
but then when you seem like holy fire
dude read it but then it's like word of
mouth and then Chris goes oh you like
that video yeah post something else then
he gets on the mmm of rap video say like
I'd watch [ __ ] shirt watch back I've
went back and watched Krista Leah's
Instagram clips to Eminem things or the
thing we you
where you know he's doing uh when he was
those Laurel Yanni sounds from last I
watch it a thousand times I've watched
your videos when you know you're driving
through the mountains of Utah with your
kids I've watched a thousand times I
jerked off all your content that's the
way you move I'm saying I've watched the
wall and it's open
I'm a fan of you guys because I don't
listen to the podcast that much cuz I
don't at the time on Grindr and all that
[ __ ] what I'm saying here but yeah I'm a
bug chaser and I got to go to [ __ ]
Banco Popular and all that from my
Puerto Rican family and metaphorically
no but it's all good I love Puerto Rico
foreign hand um I'm confused yeah and
and and but my point is that I consume
your guys stuff I'm like I'm a fan I
know what you guys do because I'm
watching your social medias you know I'm
not at the live shows and when I times
like when I do consume your podcasts
through the clips yeah and I think
that's great that's like what mommies
next what happens in five years ten
years everywhere we did it I'll let you
know how it goes yeah I'll let you know
I feel like I'll live life is he up
there I'll let you know daddy almost got
an accident driving back from Manhattan
Beach and saw myself a whale saw myself
a whale got a whale blue whale I don't
know but I saw this giant whale and and
I went I was on the phone with chrome I
go Bob I'm looking at a whale right yeah
right 6000 you seen some and then it
can't and then it came back up and I
almost ran into a [ __ ] divider
yeah rightfully so dumb whales are
beautiful yeah almost be killed young
else because absolutely because we are
peanut oil
yeah and they call the whales I think
carry rabies absolutely I do I don't
know I think that yeah and yeah killing
a [ __ ] whale [ __ ] well man they're
all in Isis yeah yeah they're cool to
see though it's really our coldest ebook
it was really well to see that it was a
hundred feet
you know it's nice but it's like let's
move on you know we got [ __ ] VR
virtual reality I could with this and
the guy was in and in Santa Cruz have
been telling us Erin's health story
you've been telling story since I don't
know since you were 15
yeah and everything I've been telling
you like this I was like and the guy was
paddling and a great white came up put
him in his mouth all the way to his hips
and then spit him back out I remember
he's dead sir so I tell me this I don't
know you story thousand times because I
heard it from somebody a long time ago
do I remember who no no but it's true
it's true and Brennan goes Jesus that's
crazy and I'm talking he goes hey but
that never happened I was like no
because I was told and you got to do an
inventory of the stories you tell cuz we
tell stories sometimes and we forget
where we heard him and their crew yeah
they're probably not yeah there's like a
guy in my neighborhood ski we call him
Showtime and he tells [ __ ] wild
stories and like yeah and then I was
telling this story once to my dad and
you know he this guy was telling the
story the neighbor for ten years and I'm
like yeah Showtime said one time he
punched a hole in a wall and he behind
the wall to [ __ ] Mickey Mantle rookie
card and he pulled down here as a as a
micced man through vocal Mickey Mantle
rookie card and I was like that's not
true I was like no he punched a hole in
the wall there was a Mickey Mantle
rookie card behind it and he's like no
it's not true why would you ever do
stories your dad told you I think it
stories my dad's own when I was younger
it has now more I'm like oh he was full
of [ __ ] there's stories my dad told me
that it were definitely lies but then my
mother who does not lie and some of the
stories she tells me about my dad I'm
like what cuz my dad was nuts he was
like a criminal alive he's alive he's
alive but he was like a [ __ ] he's my
dad hits a kind of guy my dad is
old-school guy you know like Bronx guy
organized crime type [ __ ] you know in
and out of jail when I was a kid you
know and he's 75 years old now he's
diabetic you know [ __ ] he almost died
actually the day after Christmas guy ate
half of tray of lasagna like four
cannolis I love it three cups of coffee
to any vodka and then you know I'm just
watching me but then I'm like I got to
step in I'm like dad what are you doing
it goes alright or no I
okay son I'm like okay and then [ __ ] -
three hours later when the ER item means
gargle and I'm like who sounds gay now
just a park dog yeah I swear to God but
my dad used to tell me stories I'm like
no way but there's one story and my mom
confirmed it so my mom my dad is not a
great looking guy I mean yawning yeah so
you know and my mother's a beautiful
woman she went to an Ivy League school
and you know they met at a walkathon and
my mom was walking the walkathon raising
money for like a great cause and my dad
was doing community service on the side
as a walkathon prison work-release and
they wanted to she want to have like a
fling with the bad boy and they had me
so my mom's kind of stuck with this guy
now and they were at Central Park
my mother's 21 years old when she had me
so at Central porno was you dead my dad
my mother was 21 with Jenn and my dad
was 38 so my dad yeah it's an older kid
oh yeah dad so so they were laying down
in Central Park and my mom was like
seven months pregnant she had like a
blanket over her and my dad in the
middle of [ __ ] day gets up to take a
piss behind a tree in the middle of
Central Park so he's my mom's just
sitting there like reading a book and
Dan Aykroyd was rollerblading by a
roller skating by and and he started
hitting on my mother my dad chased dan
Aykroyd like down a lane at Central Park
with a [ __ ] twit yeah with this kiss
it's the height of fame Danny I was like
no that's like wow [ __ ] and it's true
yeah yeah this guy did your dad hasn't
beat the [ __ ] I don't know no you skated
away bonehead in Florida in Florida
I'm at a strip club with us with a
[ __ ] cop SWAT guy and some MMA
fighters okay you gotta come to the
strip club we haven't how long does this
be I need probably probably no no six
years ago I don't like strip clubs but
before before you met me no I think it
was during this probably I knew you okay
and I'm doing standard but might have
been but might have been like I would
say right when I met okay and yeah and
so I'm gonna watch this bouncer this big
[ __ ] bouncer there's a white black
white white Italian any more time before
I was sick what color God
this story's made up so blue
he had a shirt on him oh [ __ ] so I
watched the dude take this dude this
other guy big guy and he puts him in
this hole and his face didn't change
nothing on his face change right but it
was a violent situation and he put him
in this thing act it up yeah this is the
bouncer so these guys are fighting these
guys are about to fight okay
okay over and they lock they lock up I
don't know what the [ __ ] was two
tables okay lock up this guy walks over
and I was struck with how easy his face
didn't move right grabs the guy and they
yank him out like that I get to talk to
him cuz he comes over and he knows one
of the guys were with right and I say at
him we start talking and I say you you
didn't seem to like your face that
seemed like such order of the day that
was a scary situation that guy was big
right it looked rough and I got nervous
yeah and he said he said if not on
violence never gets me going at all I
was raised differently and I go do tell
yeah I go what was your dad what he goes
well my dad's in prison for life and
that was a wise guy right he was a
killer right and I go oh and he tells me
a story about how you need to talk about
stories whether this is true or not this
is one I believe him he goes he goes my
dad my dad was a wise guy he had a comic
book store that was like part of that
but yeah and he said I was 12 years old
and I would I would have to school I'd
be with my dad in the comic book store
working or whatever and a [ __ ] two
guys walked in and my dad they walked in
my dad looked at him pulled out a
shotgun and shot both of them but one of
them he blew his [ __ ] hat off in the
ripen that never happened so then he my
dad looked at me and goes go get a mop
at a comic book store yeah hmm and but
they came in to kill him and he killed
those guys I don't think so he said he
said that was what I remember that was
my childhood right yeah and I I actually
believe that god I don't I don't not
believe I'm I believed in because you
worked in that one of those models and
worked one of those mob strip clubs yeah
you know it I mean yeah yeah what could
he mean comic books I don't know I
didn't ask him I didn't I didn't
kirill Amanat I just sometimes you have
some questions you know get a model it's
also seen out of Natural Born Killers
but whatever already nice to each its
own it's a good movie
yeah that's great well I believe I
believe it because that story never
happened I made it out but the point is
no that's no hey but who cares that's
the thing is just a suggestion who cares
what the no dude I mean it doesn't
matter you not if I want to do that in
Dover what are you gonna say to me
that's what I want to [ __ ] do I want
to I'm in you it I want to live in an
igloo and I want to get reek I want to
get sexual reassignment surgery and live
in the Canadian [ __ ] tell him no
gender it's not sexual number Sam you
guys say gender reassignment sir
whatever it is but I'm just saying I
supported that those are my fans
Wow yeah see fans yes yes you got hold
on I'll be I'll be not big he's big yeah
give me your list your favorite fighters
I love what this is not a good beat
Mighty Mouse I like that kid so who do I
like Anton
he's a good guy yeah I like him I like
Dominick Cruz is a good fighter
yep man I like Jam years I got to admit
I like McGregor I do like my car yeah
tell you what I went out one night at an
after a New York Knicks game with stops
topics s steep a steep a they came from
Ohio right yes young-hee Croatian
descent right but he's from I'll right
he wasn't drinking but we were getting
[ __ ] smash sure so my boy patty
flyballs we drinking vodka sodas to the
head we must had 1215 vodka sodas Nelson
I get blackout drunk I had sex with a
famous lesbian chef I [ __ ] wake up I
swear to god dude I wake up the next day
and I see this lesbian chef who I know
from TV once she look naked making
pancakes and I'm like did we have sex I
say and she goes you bet your ass we did
I was a kid but don't you like women she
was like I cruised for [ __ ] once a year
and you were the lucky [ __ ] I was like
grew up all over for ya what the kid
stops topic or whatever steep XD pay
[ __ ] around I was and I was like doing
like I was trying to punch him in the
stomach and he put me in a headlock
that's like for fun and I was joking
around but I remember for about six
months I couldn't move my head to the
right dude I'd love to see this lesbian
chef yeah well I'll tell you after the
show cuz I have to you know I have to
Gang puck
no it wasn't yeah it was no no I can't
wait it was what no I [ __ ] bang and
her name was Guy Fieri yeah you went to
flavortown do it she made these pancakes
that were unbelievably the last time in
my life this was two years ago that's a
laugh I was drinking with Ari Shaffir
Ari Shaffir was there luis jay gomez me
patty fly balls and we were at new york
new york knicks game and we went to this
party after and then I remember she made
these [ __ ] pancakes and I like wanted
to eat them but I was so drunk and
hungover that I just threw up all over a
kitchen floor never again never heard
from her again I mean I tried to text
her get into our restaurants and all
that [ __ ] I was like no she was like
it's once a year and that's it but yeah
we have the same haircut we look it's
kind of like I [ __ ] my brother and I'm
an only child so I'm not saying if I had
a brother I wouldn't have tried the
[ __ ] but not but she had a dick on her
she had a dick on what you have secretly
an ass do you who do you think is gonna
win this is it gonna be Donald Cerrone
or Calloway McGregor
I think Cowboys gonna maybe upset him
yeah yeah I don't even think is that
much of an update well yeah typically it
would be yeah but I said 100 on I mean
what your stickers gonna roll over
that's not true isn't that weird to you
it's a little bit weird is 170 yeah my
boy has lost the last two fights though
he has losses to last and I thought eyes
want to find three years though right
and I haven't seen and am I out of it I
haven't seen any talk any hype now why
is that I don't know there's nothing so
weird to me right
they might go build up here's the other
things that your UFC goes I don't know
if they announced it maybe Dana did a
little bit he didn't really dive into it
but they go fastest sellout t-mobile we
saw out 30 minutes and even that was you
know a few weeks ago even I was like
that damn compact but they look more
into a lot of BOTS but the tickets the
the tickets are every game by him yeah
why does only knows why he's like not to
do as Connor
he hasn't done press B the yeah he
doesn't want to fight three years I mean
you know there's a lot that goes into it
yeah and I wonder if yes we might he
might be yeah he might be a little
nervous about creating a lot of hype if
he lose no I don't think he's nervous I
just think he said if you saw his
interview like great interview with E
rouhani seasoner he's dialed in yep
you're Connor feeling like oh yeah he
said he hasn't he hasn't had a drink in
like months three for my buds yeah which
I was like Donald Donald sticks to the
game plan kicks front kicks him I would
front kick him and game plan you have a
Brendan when you were fighting did you
ever like two questions one did you ever
go into a fight like if the fights the
arena and you had to poop or pee pee
like everyone - do you ever get you ever
get kicked in the face and what what
really knocked out was the smell of the
guy's foot
those are legit questions because I know
people ask you all these what's it like
I know that you're fearless and a maniac
and nuts and you have mental health
issues because you're fighting in the
[ __ ] Octagon like that I know that
that's true but I want to know what guys
like Anna CMS do a poop or pee pee yeah
every I think every time you do your
nurse you have to pee
so every fight you have to pee yeah and
I know because I know like people have
asked like him a roll around a guy get
like attracted to a guy because that
would be my thing
no I'm not trying to be funny my thing
would be fighting with a guy like that
especially a handsome guy like you like
if you were my opponent I would train
and I'd be like I want to kill you but
then if we're nestling up like that and
especially if you catch me with a kick
you know to certain part of my body and
I get an erection
the ribs are you into getting kicked
around oh no
right now Brendan I'm like it right I'm
not looking me in the eye
nah you know what happened to getting
kicked around I'm into starting
monogamous relationships with men I feel
like you're being metaphorical but I'm
super do is get a [ __ ] mortgage with
you man you're [ __ ] really
good-looking I'm warning you no but I
just I don't know you know yeah wouldn't
I wouldn't know the answer to that
question your money I was able to fight
the drought cold then where's your money
on this where's your money on this fight
oh you know I love Donald I love Donald
but if cowboy everybody Cerrone comes
correct so I mean if Connor comes
correct he's really yeah you think
Connors okay at 170 like being like I
think so cuz because Cerrone he's not a
huge 170 you know he's not like a like a
Darren tail or a Woodley or one of those
monsters like sorority real weight was
55 he is successful at 55 he's good at
70 but they're both tweeners so it makes
for Connors comeback fight it makes all
the sense of the world right it diving I
want out I love I love Donald and Don's
a personal friend I just wanted to get
paid yeah that's wrong we get paid right
because even if he wins there's not a
lot left for right just get paid yeah
for the sport it's way better if Connor
went way better for those business it's
way better yeah he only beats like
little or guys who's that Connor like he
never the second time but I mean it was
like it could have kind of got if there
was like a little more time on the clock
he could've got choked out the hour
dude dude small but yummy yummy yummy
yummy because I was 185 and he's always
not small no are there any gay UFC
fighters there are Allen that came out
just there's a few female Lisbon's yeah
I feel I mean all but the chef ya know
Kurt events it again
I hear what happened what's going on the
yeah so a woman is currently suing
American Airlines because last year
there was a worker who found her bag got
her phone number from the little tag and
started texting her before and during
the flight he ended up getting arrested
as soon as they landed in Chicago and
she tried to stay silent about the whole
thing but she finally got a lawyer and
now they are suing because he did this
to a couple other women it's interesting
it's actually it's interesting that that
happens and that and and it sucks that
happen but two weeks ago I went to Best
Buy
and I bought something for my TV and
they used my credit card and my
information was saved and the girl
behind the register at Best Buy started
texting me about three hours later
telling me that she thought I was hot
and if I wanted to hang out and and she
was like I can come over I have your
address and she was you know she's like
I if she's like a young hot enough girl
but I was like it freaked me out I was
like wow this was if I did that to her
right I'd be on I'd be on [ __ ] is she a
hot chick she was a hot come on over
don't know my [ __ ] textures like you
have a hot somebody said no such night
up the wrong tree the rolls are [ __ ]
wat the roll in front so as well but I
mean this is a creepy [ __ ] dude you
can't do that but I mean also it's like
there was no physical contact like what
is the lawyer gonna do it's locked and a
girl give you her number on a by
gramming gonna give you a number on a
flight serious sound most of the fight
like this ready Southwest watch this and
she was taking it I look good I look
come on so long yes I like the neck yep
yeah yeah hey do you like that neck
don't say anything about my Tommy Lee
Jones net I have a nice neck I know a
good neck I have and that's good skin on
my neck my neck looks like a slinky
which is a [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of hey
yeah but it's good I got a good neck I
know listen yeah I mean gave me her
number as I go I was so flattered I
couldn't take it and much younger
oh you might deny her the kid still has
it what's the age would ever be no I was
just impressed yeah I was like
[ __ ] made my day that ain't creepy
out there did it now keep creeped me out
there's nothing a woman could do to
creep me out I had a woman got drunk and
sat next to me like the other guy got
out and she was a big gal older and
drunk as [ __ ] I'm drinking tomato juice
yeah I'm like tomato I'm being honest
the only thing about a woman that's ever
really creeped me out is when they have
vaginas start to be like I'm gonna call
my lawyer spread that [ __ ] because I I
[ __ ] have a family man I know that
okay so Tyson Fury says that leading up
to the fight he is actively masturbating
about seven times a day in order to get
his testosterone levels high enough Wow
Wow that's science coming out if you
jerking off yeah am i wrong that would
be well no bro no science is not coming
that's also when old-school boxers who
and fighters UFC fighters use fingers to
when they think not having sex to save
their testosterone and make sure they're
not sure off that's not true cuz when
you're not busting nuts your
testosterone goes we're good fellas that
shut down he's not using us all right so
it lowers your test thought you wanted a
lobby busting I know a few fighters who
bust nuts the day up what you have
sexual intercourse before the fight I'm
good whenever you could have filled up
during the fight sure sweaty it's yes no
loop yeah thinking about all right oh my
god yeah yeah yeah this save he's gonna
do it he's a wild looking guy it's been
fun awesome yeah
and I'm willing to try it for this fight
he's being silly
yeah listen got a key I've got a seven
times you ever done it seven times no
nine times
no I jerked off four times on Monday for
is my record that was my record cuz I'm
in a hotel when you're in a hotel you
got nothing on I've listened a little
with you so yeah thanks or an immersion
tanks we do that kids put enough I see
hot tub did do that once yeah like
vassal you know that I yeah it burns
manage teenager it wasn't a good we did
the immersion tank he comes out like
this the float tank before you know it
Rogan talked about going you floats we
don't giggling like what's up because I
was like I sure didn't but everybody
else does yeah I never here's a filter
system oh so take it easy I've never I
did bust a fat load in one of those flow
take rice man they did its warm water
and the warm water just splat and you
probably exotic about it and then you
shake it everywhere like I can't relax
what's this hmm
really and you're definitely kid that
you shoot [ __ ] ropes ah I don't go
inside dominoes but I'm saying if I know
this kid's got a [ __ ] healthy
prostate that shooting ropes
yeah alright maybe white worms but ropes
oh man whatever it is man yeah I can't
do those tanks maybe bang maybe I'm a
little older I try it now you know how
old years ago 36 good age man we're the
same old old old yeah we're two old kids
I'm on one forty fifty wow wow you look
good I'm gonna kiss every little crease
on that
let me dance I was so excited and then
you [ __ ] know it
no it's natural it's not that young you
won't know you're young you're young
cool stupid stop the honest I feel like
you least wrinkles out any of us here
though yeah Green Mile let's be real
that's sure thanks you wanna lose your
shirt you gotta you gotta Harry with
hair in it when the shirt comes off yeah
it's gross yeah guys in New York body
Zeki sausage yeah show me with Harriet
tonight alright we're gonna show
together tonight we're laughs factor
that factor yeah oh [ __ ] have you ever
felt more disrespected on a podcast geez
I believe he believes nothing you say
he's accused you being gay like a
hundred times seven I mean it's like a
little it's what [ __ ] pile on welcome
I mean right I believe you
honestly I'm always telling you holy
thing I know can I formally apologize do
be I mean clarify yeah please do so
first of all I'm sorry I gave you that
impression yeah they're the only thing I
think is that I and I I think I believe
that you're a straight guy of course my
hunch but I do believe you fought guys
so last night last night I'll [ __ ] be
100% on speak last night I was on Santa
Monica Boulevard and I got I brought
thought with me I brought a song and I
pull my pants down a little bit I have
the thong and I'm showing people as
they're going to the intersection I'm
trying to wave people off the side of
the road because I want to pee on some
guys back and I want to do that away
peel guys back and I got Yanis filming a
crispy kale it's something that I like
to check on you do whatever you want got
me man specifically straight man that's
maybe coming home from work and I just
want to tell his family about it and I
wanted you to have like a little ladder
friend if you were wearing a crop top
then we got initiator I'm telling you
I'm wearing this at least you're on the
same page when I'm wearing a Yankees
watch it okay okay yep Yankee no I
couldn't agree more
absolutely man it's not exit or anything
like that the hotel almost ain't a hotel
in West Hollywood in my place I'm gonna
sniff your feet tonight yeah that's
what's gonna happen here a big kid we're
gonna [ __ ] wrestle baseball ain't no
good here yeah okay so yesterday at LAX
there was a flight taking off to
Shanghai in about 24 minutes out they
said that there was some engine failure
so they turned around yeah and as they
were getting back to LAX they started to
drop a jet fuel and it happened to hit
over an elementary school she's hose
those kids down yeah what can you do
yeah what do you turn a teenager you
ninja yeah that's yeah you know that's
yeah you on must now yeah yeah it's
their fault for having to school closed
uh private school published I said I
think it's public there you go Yeah
right public school yells in private
school kids yeah yeah public school kids
are the ones roads decock yeah and I'm
sure it wasn't and I'm sure it wasn't a
white neighborhood right yeah I'm sure
it wasn't I'm sure was a [ __ ]
neighborhood yeah yeah and the next
thing you know Isis coming up yeah yeah
was his Spirit Airlines that that
happened it was a Chinese airliner close
the damn Chinese yeah he means that
affectionately I mean I was just kidding
just transgender yeah we got trans man
that alive the emails just say thank you
yeah no no I'm kidding around that
starts with the jet wherever why
wouldn't i to be sure why won't they go
over the ocean and dump it they probably
couldn't usually needed to let go of
more weight in order to land the plane
properly just do some reason invited to
dump like right before as they were pull
sounds like they targeted them a little
sway over an elementary school fire yeah
sprinkling like all this [ __ ] gas wow
that's [ __ ] up but everybody's okay
surprisingly yeah I mean it happens
light him on fire the most of the worst
yeah big deal no problem yeah what else
alright so I'm gonna play a song I'm
sure you guys probably recognize it
we're not gonna be easy sign there but
I'll play it first we'll see all right
let me you know the song right yeah oh
yeah he does it shake it ranks shake it
wrinkles did you dick out what about
this though chin oh man you know this
song yeah we don't so the artists the
artists name is yung Joc yeah and he was
recently caught on camera driving an
uber and I'll play it this is the people
that recorded him come on man are the
hustles real dude
you sound like somebody I know oh no God
well they trying to add yeah just leave
him alone I don't know whose name okay
if I call her a [ __ ] she's being a
[ __ ] huh she's a [ __ ] oh it's a woman
yeah what made finally guy working at
Whole Foods or Trader Joe's Osby show
yeah yeah oh so they're saying that so
they found out his young jock I know he
must have fell off he's actually
actually saying to him behind me back in
the water
tell me took him out and beat the [ __ ] I
don't know he's actually been who's
super nice and calm and cordial but
turns out so he's he does something like
big brothers and sisters of uh I think I
Lana so he's trying to show the kids to
make an honest living it's not gonna be
you shouldn't be embarrassed yeah oh
yeah maybe rap doesn't pay all the bills
and by the way he actually makes good
money like he does a bunch stuff still
yeah he does hosting stuff you don't
love in hip-hop
yeah love this guy more yeah I love how
that she thought that was gonna be a
story about again and now it's just a
story about her being a [ __ ] but she's
you know we don't know who she is fans I
figure it out yeah what's the video say
though here this is him just explaining
what he was doing new rector year new
trainer he's just a good dude
25 years Big Brother Big Sister and a
lot of times when we talking to these
kids and again you gotta lead by example
and sometimes I was like you have to
show people you not to be you know I'm
saying yeah shoulder what humility is
and you got to be to you know do the
right thing by making an honest living I
think a lot of times that's why our kids
and even adults going straight because
they too ashamed too prideful Manson do
something it was one of those things
like you know you just be you started
challenging stuff to do something you
never did before so it's kind of yeah I
mean he needs the money but yeah that's
a great job he's like he's like hey
Jeffrey
so I got caught riding a new I probably
say that to drive an uber knob that's a
bummer though that he knows people suck
he definitely needs the money pay the
bills but those people suck so my tax
revenue you might notice is those people
suck they do some good good for you
better than me I'm [ __ ] on yeah
sorry was to I have to make extra money
to for my family yeah so he's a radio
the town appears on love and hip hop and
just opened a new club yes yeah maybe
he's just a hustler man like sad I mean
he's for sure's do like look man I'm
karaoke and cars thing I'm not taking my
shoe off
those are nice kicks those are really
nice what size you to the next [ __ ] last
[ __ ] that'll be the last guy coke I'm
sorry at last Cleveland the end of this
month hilarities yeah Antonio Brown it
was a bag of dicks at baby mama yeah so
apparently she's supposed to come by and
pick up the kids and then he's accusing
her of trying to take one of his cars -
and then this ensued so there's a video
of him throwing three bags I don't think
that the videos actually spirited but he
kind of went off gummi dicks Oh gummy -
yeah oh shut up I'll play a little bit
of this this is from Barstow
[ __ ] come on [ __ ] that's him filming it
yep you live on Instagram oh the [ __ ] I
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
did the fall that's good to do it for me
I'm saying it's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of here I love you puppy
that's the [ __ ] you're talking [ __ ]
about the police as well cop you wish
you could take me you [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] out here Jesus yeah in the
back of the police car fishbowl real
evil with [ __ ] please get the [ __ ] out
you bum [ __ ]
oh this is depressing so anyways I
promised kids you should see TAC team
that's an [ __ ] no thanks up [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's not CT right people are
playing to anything in the CT stuff like
lady it's not me it's Benny he made a
mad even right and unbearable to cochon
I'm be able to play absolutely he's an
[ __ ] I called somebody fish ball is
funny I mean I'm gonna call somebody
fish ball tonight if they happen I
didn't get the fish got a body like if
you had a boxy body official watch your
mouth fish ball yeah oh you're [ __ ]
two kids I just got a great example
disgusting man Wow
yeah it's listen why he says this he
thinks his wife looks like a fish that's
why I called you first of all she got
arrested but then they're yelling if
she's not arrested he got arrested he's
telling the cops are bitch-ass [ __ ]
yeah that's great yeah
so here's the other thing said aloud can
the cops arrest you for now they won't
be a property at the eff good I agree
but as soon as house gets robbed who you
think is gonna call and be praying that
they come there yeah but then he puts
this brown also acknowledges that the
standoff isn't the best look for
Xenophon future but quote [ __ ] the NFL
this is real life yeah [ __ ] yeah dude
yeah right so good let's watch this for
a second he's back right no so he's
actually allowed to play at their
facilities the police facilities and
then that something they worked out but
then now they cut ties cuz of this you
have to its sad sad guy spiral is he so
still good he still could is good top
300 right now
so fast
I can't tell by just watching them touch
but the most bummer thing is doing that
in front of his kids brutal yeah
and talking smack on the cops - he's a
[ __ ] it is he ever gonna play again
bring the wild pigs Dom I don't think I
can know who would sign up like a cat
anymore you know because of all this
stuff this is I guess you supported him
before saying you should get a chance at
the NFL but now after this he's like no
anymore is it super law loves to unite I
love all my god I love Steven Naismith I
wouldn't let up with him bring him on my
NFL team I can't happen yeah I know that
not anymore he's got problems [ __ ] we
just said and I learned nothing but
learned nothing and it's not good he was
yelling at the cops very cool very cool
you like cement original take though
let's go Wow front of the kids and I and
I did say cops will arrest you typically
for that right you're being they can
easily do it if they wanted sure yeah
property even sure I'm pretty sure if
he's being what do you know what are you
home in jail what do you do that's
that's more paperwork for them like I
yeah this is strange and this is strange
self saboteur doesn't seem right yeah I
think I'm not using any of it as an
excuse but I'm saying like no sidered
for an NFL team it's like his mental
health is priority it's like you're
watching a man who's going insane yeah
like he can't even considering but also
if the Broncos signed him tomorrow I'd
have a Antonio Brown Jersey is he is he
absolutely yes still has a lot of money
because you've missed out on 90 million
dollars yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so
that's that I fell in the league
receiver for a long time you know wow I
would assume you know what you don't
know if I don't make those moves that
have ton of money in the bank yeah I'm
saying I mean and don't forget taxes on
1k plan when you make your moves like
I'm a forty 1 million dollars this year
I needed like 20 million hi hon how did
you make is pod Comedy Central
Comedy Central man stupid question
interstitial show I told you 5 min that
you're lying about saying you know I'm
not saying you're lying about that but I
do believe you [ __ ] man you have sex
with a condom it doesn't count so not
that one this guy remember your boy his
name is David Baker I guess he used to
play of court a sketball not football
why he never blamed balls in that Edward
er it might be from the Dallas Cowboys
David Baker imagine he's man someone
showed me this and this leather suit Wow
he's sweating Brendan Schaub every
shellfish does your dad look like that
yeah he looks like Fred Flintstone he
looks like a shaved polar bear that's
why he's sweating out of his goddamn
shoes cry so he's the president of the
Football Hall of Fame sure he played
football I don't think so then why would
they make him the [ __ ] president what
is he the president of oh you like him
he plays he had to play football
uh-oh basketball in Switzerland what is
that he thinks foot nine Baker tip
scales at nearly 400 pounds Wow by
professional basketball in Switzerland
as a young boy six basketball players
are labeled when their body lets loose
you know they're still Superman they put
on boys big big boys nobody blew out
like Buster Douglas you remember the way
he blew out after he beat Tyson it's
like eating a big yeah and Yuri says
hold my tamale but yeah I hear you yeah
I love Andy Ruiz do you I well I don't
know I'm not in boxing enough I just
watch it from like I don't know much
about the fighting sports but I just
liked after the after when he lost the
fight the most recent fight they're like
what do you think happened out there he
was like I ate too much I was like I
really wasn't training I ate too much
food so yeah I think we're smiling it's
like Mexico he liked it like rematch it
was like yeah I'll take it serious time
this guy's great want to talk about a
[ __ ] baa Jesus Christ Anthony Joshua
Holy Smoke [ __ ] going the sauna I get
real nice and wet yeah
not some bugs with him dude yeah oh yeah
for sure man what are you saying that
cuz he's blacked those Mexicans don't
Anthony Joshua do one more that we're
done it's not a big deal but McDonald's
is gonna start using msg and apparently
this is like a big deal this probably
makes it healthier who cares MSG is
usually Vanek I heard it doesn't give
you a headache
I heard it's all yes it somehow came out
and there's even the Miriam Webster
dictionary said it there's something
called CRS Chinese restaurant syndrome
it's actually in there real and all that
stuff like you get dizzy you know what
all that stuff like it's supposed to be
real but pop art yeah Popeyes
chick-fil-a they all use it delicious
ms/ms true so when McDonald says we're
listen to our customers that means
people asked for a mystery our testing
and people liked the taste of it better
yeah yeah what Chinese food American
Chinese food that's like oh make sure
that doesn't have msf flavor right it's
a weird thing
interesting interesting so wait is it
not bad for you to get mouth sodium
glutamate yes yeah we're like Rick and
Morty over here dude what you like it
dude
that is the best kind this is the best
podcast of all no seriously the spot and
and the gays and the yeah yes okay ready
get ready for your number so delicious
oh it's great it's not we a [ __ ]
burger guys after this [ __ ] yes I do
hotel and then let's go like this and
drive fast like have you ever you ever
just rock out yeah put on um put on Ted
Nugent's stranglehold so I can show you
how you rock out I'd like to see that
I'd like to see this yeah yeah always
audio people by you take your pants off
via people my age understand rock are
you [ __ ] idiots don't know yeah young
dudes don't matter [ __ ]
nope Rock yeah take your wig off double
live gonzo maybe take your wig off
take your wig off rock out with the wig
off so hey show me your bottom teeth
[Music]
yeah
slap that slap it yeah that was good
though man hey you're just distracting
okay have more stuff in your pocket yeah
yeah hell yeah you're not old at all put
more stuff in your pockets like a
janitor yeah yeah yeah dude yeah baby
roll while your jeans up so we can see
your psoriasis Road jeans up yeah this
is up went from uncomfortably gay to
uncomfortably white yeah now that's the
longest song in history whatever anyway
a rock bro not in my pocket it's 20
bucks hey Cleveland
you guys want a [ __ ] lap if you don't
want to constantly have a go this is the
best [ __ ] so I've ever seen
don't come to Cleveland hilarious July
January 1st 1st of February yeah boys
West Palm Beach improv for Valentine's
Day 1560 now I go hard I'm in San Jose
this weekend zeroes in a million guys
it's call me when you're serious you
[ __ ]
I'm in San Jose this weekend two shows
Friday to show Saturday's almost sold
out we had a Sunday show one show Sunday
nights come and get it
next week Charlotte comedies on I think
that's a Thursday Friday Saturday then
Columbus Ohio January 1st through
February 1st
San Antonio Ontario Valentine's Day
weekend and then Vancouver jfl comedy
festival once you only vote Theater
Vancouver get tickets deep at kake.com
fellas yeah I got January 24th Spaceland
bottom hand in Connecticut those tickets
are almost sold out yeah a celebrity
theater Atlantic City New Jersey those
tickets are almost sold on then I got
February 8th at the Kennedy Center
Washington DC that would need some help
February 28th hilarities in Cleveland
that would also need some help guys
let's do it I'll make a speech
Christianity calm yeah Christi comedy
calm slash grinder
oh nice you're gonna say yeah check out
it special but very guys check out my
special blowing the light yeah blowing
the light on YouTube I'll be at Gotham
comedy club February 21st to 22nd uncle
Vinny's comedy club in Point Pleasant
New Jersey 28th and 29th of February
dude I'm in New York at Gotham I think
in April we come to our potty when
you're in I'm done there dude and you
guys are gonna be there too oh you know
what comment let's do it what do you
call comic yeah well yeah when is the
man dragon coming
huh you [ __ ] oh yeah dragon decides to
fly in and [ __ ]
the comedy landscape [ __ ] no [ __ ]
nonsense and fantastic fantastic party
bad you guys are good oh yeah